what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
unfortunately we have a little bit of a
different video here sadly we have some
bad news in the marvel community today
as a marvel actor has died gaspard uliel
who was going to be playing a character
in the upcoming moon night disney plus
show that marvel studios is producing
unfortunately has passed away he was 37
years old and he died in a skiing
accident he died on january 17th and
according to the website france blue he
was skiing in la rosia savoir and he
collided with another skier and
according to the reports he was
unconscious when the medics arrived and
was said to be suffering from serious
head trauma he was then transported by
helicopter to grenoble university
hospital and then he was shortly later
pronounced dead after having surgery and
the other skier who he collided with
apparently did not require any type of
hospitalization and walked away fine
this is actually kind of surreal because
i actually was skiing yesterday and it
can be very dangerous when two paths
collide which is what is said to have
happened here two different slopes
combined into one which is where he ran
into the other skier coming from the
other slope now gaspard was cast for
marvel's moon knight as anto mogart
midnight man who is a villain in marvel
comics he is a thief and a collector and
according to imdb which may not be
entirely accurate he is in all six
episodes of moon night gaspard is best
known for portraying hannibal lecter in
2000's hannibal rising he was also in a
2010 commercial directed by martin
scorsese for chanel this is definitely a
very tragic event he was a new member to
the marvel family and thoughts and
prayers go out to his family as well
you